joining us here is football morning in
america column as always must read back
here on the show
a colleague from nbc sports right here
on nbc sports on peacock channel on
peacock
is none other than peter king how are
you peter
rich everything is going well i just
voted would you vote
oh you mean uh for for uh our poll
question or the presidential election
peter
no no i voted in the in the election
i voted at barclays center this morning
oh you did in brooklyn only a seven
only a seven minute wait it was very
nice well i mean you're lucky as we know
that
seven hours is uh something people in
this country would be signing up for
because of how difficult
it's been made to vote in certain parts
so i'm glad you exercised your
democratic right sir to vote that's uh
fantastic
indeed yeah it was good it was good okay
so
uh who do you vote for in that poll
question then how about that to start us
off whose weapons would you want would
you take chiefs bucks
cardinals or seahawks peter
um well i would take
chiefs but i'd have a slight asterisk
there
okay and the slight asterisk is
just the fact that even though i would
vote for the chiefs
i would also be concerned about the
health
of those uh weapons because
they have guys who are speedsters
and uh who are not built like dk metcalf
the amazing thing about the play last
night is dk metcalf has built like
a tight end and on some teams might even
be scouted as such
but he also runs a 434-440 and
you know so i i would i would take
kansas city
but i wouldn't necessarily go shouting
to the moon about it i i think
i think you could make a case for for
almost all of that i don't know that you
could make a case for the running back
in seattle
compared to the other ones but all those
places have good
skill positions they sure do they sure
do uh let's start i guess with
the steelers peter since they're the
lone remaining undefeated team
now that arizona did pull off that win
late
last night um uh the steelers are gonna
be taking the ravens on next
just uh one great hit after another in
the afc
how do you see the steelers setting up
for a long run potentially to tampa
right now peter well the answer the
interesting thing
i wrote about this today is that the
difference between pittsburgh
and almost every other team is
they have probably i
i might call them five game changers on
offense
and you know roethlisberger connor and
three of their receivers and then
they've got at least four
on defense that
could make a huge play in any game and
so
you know i think i think pittsburgh has
the depth
at impact positions on both sides of the
ball
that very very few teams in the nfl have
right now and i
i really like pittsburgh and yet
tennessee almost pulled it off again
i mean they they're well tennessee you
know
tennessee is is right in there right in
the same league
with pittsburgh i mean their defensive
play makers are not as famous
and they their defense is not as good as
pittsburgh's but it's not far away from
pittsburgh
and you know to me i think that
you know what we saw yesterday is that
for a good chunk of the game
they took derrick henry and his impact
away from the game
especially in the first half and so
you know when they do that
you know but but then again you saw ryan
tannehill
on the the sort of simple cross
uh you know to aj brown they basically
that play and i talked to tj watt about
this last night he goes
that play kept them in the game for the
entire second half
because you know you have to you have to
answer
plays like that and the steelers were
great in the first half offensively
it's interesting rich you know i try to
talk
i knew i wanted to write something about
that game so i really wanted to talk to
ben roethlisberger after the game
and i didn't know whether i was going to
or not but after the game i was told
hey listen he's a little bit ticked off
right now even though they won
so you know we'll try to get to somebody
else
um and you know i ended up getting a lot
but the interesting thing about that is
i applaud roethlisberger for being
ticked off you know because
his throw that was intercepted in the
end zone with 240 to go
you know gave the the titans that last
chance and if koskowski hits it
who knows what happens in overtime well
at least he's consistent peter because
um the first post-game show we ever had
on nfl network at a super bowl you know
writ large i mean we
our first super bowl that we we covered
first couple
um we didn't get the quarterback uh tom
brady
uh with the first two years in the
patriots but we were also still young
though
but the super bowl 40 and we were there
i mean full force
and we've been on the air a couple years
and we thought maybe this year we get
the quarterback
as you know heinz ward was the mvp of
that super bowl roethlisberger didn't
have a very good game
he didn't want to come out he wouldn't
talk so
you know it was also jerome bettis's you
know going away party
but yeah roethlisberger didn't show that
night because he was he
he i'm it's consistent if he's saying
that
then it's because he was saying that you
know yesterday
too i just think you know and look
here's the whole thing
i never ever get upset if guys
don't either they don't want to talk to
me
or they only want to do their group
thing and don't want to do any
individuals whatever
it's absolutely totally their choice i
don't have
any problem with it whatsoever because
they don't owe me
anything but it's it's always good
especially when
say that person had a major role in that
game to be able to talk to them you know
like i talked to garoppolo last night
before they got on the plane to go back
and it was it was really insightful
because
you know a guy like garoppolo in new
england
that was the kind of game that you could
say well you know just another game
it wasn't just another game it never
will be just another game
he is incredibly grateful to everybody
in new england
for what happened to him josh mcdaniels
bill belichick of course
even brady although everybody thinks
that
they've got this kind of icy
relationship i mean i don't think
they're close but
he's grateful to brady it's like aaron
rodgers is grateful to farve even though
they weren't close friends
you know uh and you did for a while
maybe he wasn't grateful but now he
realizes
that that was part of his football life
and he's grateful because he saw how
a great player was great same thing with
garoppolo
and next up for seattle is san francisco
who may be without debo
samuel because he hurt his hamstring
late in that win
um but you know they're they're down to
you know
their fourth string running back right
now and debo has been
in and out it just seems though that the
niners are hitting a stride on
on offense right now jimmy g does look
seem locked in and
boy did you know with ayuke and kittle
and when debo is healthy and
all of their running backs they arrive
with intent they are
big and they just slash and they you
know their coach gets them right on the
right angle it seems at the right time
to attack a defense
it looks like they're clicking right now
peter would you agree
remember remember the old days rich
back in the 90s and you know very early
this century when
when denver would have all these
anonymous running backs gained
a thousand yards it's a shanahan
david shanahan but but what was
the reason i bring that up right that uh
is that kyle shanahan has his dad's
running backs coach uh
you know bobby turner who hey when
when mike shanahan hired bobby turner
kyle was a sophomore in high school and
used to hang around the facility on
weekends
so you know imagine that
the the high school kid is now the coach
and the guy who taught uh
oleandes gary and terrell davis
uh mike anderson scouted him and yeah
mike anderson you know there were i
think five guys
drafted either lower who were free
agents in denver went out to gain a
thousand yards but
but be that as it may so that's the
reason why
i look at the san francisco 49ers and i
say oh
you got running back injuries give me
michael hasty this sunday they'll be
fine
and it was interesting garoppolo i
mentioned to garoppolo how impressed i
was with their running game
and he goes you know we're way ahead and
like in the last five minutes of the
game
bobby turner is on the sidelines
screaming at jemichael hasty
it's like it was a playoff game and it
was still
up for grabs but he said bobby turner is
such
a great coach because those guys are
running for their lives
i thought it was a really good point by
garoppolo peter king here
on the rich eisen show what's the
patriots answer right now
i mean just hope that cam from the first
two weeks shows up take it rich
you just you know this is going to be a
bad year
and uh you know whereas
no one puts the the black uh
you know the black crepe paper the
funeral crate paper out
for the jets or the giants because
everybody expected it
you know it's hard to feel
feel bad for the new england patriots
because they're having their first bad
year
uh in the last couple centuries you know
it's it's just
it it happens to everybody and it's
going to happen to anybody
it's it it could happen to anybody any
year
the patriots just had the gift of tom
brady for 19 years but
rich i maintained we saw this coming in
the second half of last season
when the new england patriots after
halloween had a worse record
than the miami dolphins and it you could
just see it you could see it on the
night they lost to tennessee
in the wild card game zero separation
zero weaponry uh and what did the
patriots do in the off season
they cut muhammad sanu and drafted two
tight ends in the third round
i mean it's almost like somebody it look
as
great as bill belichick is and clearly
he's one of the best coaches in
any sport ever he's got a little bit of
a blind spot about
about his skill position players
he just happens to think that they can
figure it out
at skill positions and the fact is you
better have in today's football
you better be able to find yourself
a jefferson a metcalf i'm talking a
young
impact receiver and the patriots just
simply don't have one look
they tried with um you know and keel
harry
and maybe it's too early to
throw him out with the recycling but he
certainly hasn't done it so far
well i guess at least they have bill and
you know if the cam of the first three
weeks shows up
um you know next week with the bills
ready to absolutely stomp their guts out
in the post brady era
that would be a good time for him to to
reappear at least there's that from new
england
i would agree i would agree rich but i
would
also say that
you know let's look at
one other factor here let's look at the
last couple of times
um we have seen you know
the buffalo quarterback play and say
now wait a minute did we put
uh did we put josh allen
um among the greats of the game
a little bit too early you know after
one month of the season
he looked like he absolutely
unequivocally
was justifiably of an mvp candidate
and you know he's he hasn't been as
accurate
and he hasn't been the playmaker uh the
last couple of weeks that he certainly
was early
well the reason why the reason why i
agree that buffalo ought to win this
game but
i'm i'm a little bit my eyebrows are
raised to josh allen well
right yet no doubt and the reason why i
brought that up though uh was to set up
my last question for you in the couple
minutes i have left peter king here on
the rich eisen show is you know at least
bill's there
and cam could be uh returning in the
manner in which we saw the first few
weeks
what are the answers for the cowboys
right now it seems like they are done
uh mccarthy looks like a shell of the
guy who won the super bowl
in the cowboys uh home building i i'm
only calling it like i see it right now
it seems like nobody has raised i agree
with what are they doing
i agree it it really would worry me
um not just for this year but long term
especially when you start getting
players sniping at the coach
you know what i i i mean look i named
ezekiel elliott as one of my go to the
week this week
one of the reasons i did for the full
week the two fumbles in the first half
against arizona
uh the horrible job he did on one of his
blitz pickups yesterday where he looked
totally disinterested in blocking a
blitzing washington linebacker
uh just you know he can say whatever he
wants
but ezekiel elliott looks and the word i
would use after watching a lot of that
game
ezekiel elliott looks totally
disinterested
whereas michael hasty nobody knows who
he is
but he has he runs he runs the ball
every carry
like his life depends on it ezekiel
elliott
does not look like he's running
particularly hard
or you know doing anything in terms of
blitz pickup
or blocking that is helping his team
but and i think demarcus lawrence said
it after the game last night
we have to play harder you know that's
uh
that's the only solution for the cowboys
right now
and they have a bad offensive line
because
four-fifths of a great offensive line
as of april first are all gone
you know and right now when you look at
that offensive line
that is a triple a offensive line
it's it's not good and it's hard to
blame
mike mccarthy for an offensive line
that's not good it's hard to blame him
for
prescott getting hurt and again i
do understand that you should blame mike
mccarthy
for not having the sort of commanding
presence early on
that would stop his players from yapping
that you know about how we don't like
our how we're being coached
so there's enough blame to go around but
this is a
i think it's a unique situation in
dallas peter thanks for the time
i always appreciate you uh taking me up
on a call into this show you're the best
thank you okay rich thank you
have a good day that's peter king check
out his column
uh nbcsports.com pro football talk uh
website as well um football morning in
america
hey cowboys might be one loss away from
being sellers
why not hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here